With so many rumors and news tidbits floating
around, It can be tough keeping track of what's
going on in the MCU, and what's coming up.
Well, strap on your Vibranium shield, because
we're hitting you with every project you can
expect to see in Phase 4 of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
We've been promised it would happen for years,
and on May 1, 2020, it finally will.
Black Widow, in which Scarlett Johansson will
reprise the role of superspy Natasha Romanoff
for what very well might be the last time.
The prequel is set in the period between Civil
War and Infinity War, but will likely also
flash back to the time before Romanoff's recruitment
by S.H.I.E.L.D.
According to director Cate Shortland, the
flick will find Romanoff in a dark place,
following her as she, quote, "[puts] the pieces
of herself together and [comes] out a whole
person."
Much of the action will take place overseas,
and yes, we may finally get to find out just
what went down in Budapest.
"Just like Budapest all over again."
"You and I remember Budapest very differently."
Johansson's co-stars include Florence Pugh
and Rachel Weisz, who will appear as operatives
who have undergone the same Red Room training
that honed Romanoff's deadly skills.
Also starring is David Harbour, who will portray
the Red Guardian, Russia's answer to Captain
America.
Rounding out the cast will be O-T Fagbenle
as Marcus, an underworld "fixer," and Ray
Winstone, whose role is undisclosed.
It's not yet known who will be playing the
flick's reported villain, Taskmaster, whose
photographic reflexes allow him to perfectly
mimic the fighting style of anyone he faces.
Another long-rumored project to receive final
confirmation at San Diego Comic-Con 2019 was
the Disney+ limited series The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier, which will see Anthony
Mackie and Sebastian Stan reprising their
roles of Steve Rogers' two best buddies who
just happen to kind of hate one another.
"Can you move your seat up?"
"No."
Perhaps the announcement's biggest reveal
is its logo, which sports a very Captain America-esque
design.
It seems that Sam Wilson will have a bit of
reconciling to do between his old heroic identity
and the new identity, bequeathed to him by
Rogers himself at the conclusion of Avengers:
Endgame.
Plot details have so far been kept under wraps,
but we do know one thing: the six-episode
series will see the return of Zemo, the man
who goaded the Avengers into the titular conflict
of Captain America: Civil War, and he'll be
sporting his distinctive purple mask from
the comics.
Kari Skogland will direct every episode, with
writing duties being handled by Malcolm Spellman
and Derek Kolstad.
The series won't be part of the original offerings
Disney+ will feature at launch, but is expected
to hit the streamer sometime in mid- to late
2020.
Marvel Studios opened their Comic-Con panel
with discussion of The Eternals, an interesting
if lesser-known property which should help
anchor the Cosmic side of the MCU moving forward.
The titular race of superpowered beings were
created eons ago by the Celestials to defend
the Earth from their polar opposites the Deviants.
Marvel head honcho Kevin Feige has teased
that The Eternals' story may span, quote,
"tens of thousands of years," telling an epic
story of the type we haven't yet seen in the
MCU.
The movie, which will be directed by The Rider
helmer Chloe Zhao, has assembled a suitably
epic cast for its November 6, 2020, release.
The Eternals will star Richard Madden as Ikaris,
Alongside him is Angelina Jolie as Thena,
Kumail Nanjiani as Kingo, Lauren Ridloff as
Makkari, Brian Tyree Henry as Phastos, Salma
Hayek as Ajak, and Lia McHugh as the trickster
Sprite.
The starring vehicle for the MCU's first Asian
superhero movie protagonist Shang-Chi, Master
of Kung Fu, was teased in late 2018, but until
the title was revealed at San Diego Comic-Con
in July 2019, its iconic villain had only
been rumored.
It turned out that the rumors were true: Shang-Chi
and the Legend of the Ten Rings will see the
supremely skilled fighter facing off against
the Mandarin, the classic Iron Man villain
who had been cruelly teased with Ben Kingsley's
impostor, actor Trevor Slattery, in Iron Man
3.
"Don't hurt the face!
I'm an actor!"
"You've got a minute to live, fill it with
words."
Of course, the Marvel One-Shot All Hail the
King revealed that the real deal was still
out there somewhere, and now, he'll finally
make his presence known.
It seems that the Ten Rings, the terrorist
organization who kidnapped Tony Stark in Iron
Man, will figure prominently into the screen
origin of Shang-Chi, who in the comics is
perhaps the finest unarmed combatant in existence.
Destin Daniel Cretton has been tapped to direct,
with Chinese Canadian actor Simu Liu holding
down the title role.
Also confirmed to be starring are Awkwafina
in an undisclosed role and legendary Chinese
actor Tony Leung as the Mandarin.
Rumors have already begun swirling that the
nefarious baddie will be retconned as Shang-Chi's
father in the flick, but for now, this is
unconfirmed.
We'll find out when it's released February
12, 2021.
When it was first announced in late 2018 that
Marvel Studios would be developing multiple
limited series for the Disney+ streaming service,
it didn't take long to get confirmation on
the first of these: a show about Loki, which
will see Tom Hiddleston returning to portray
the beloved trickster god once more.
While plot details remain scarce, Hiddleston
did appear during Marvel Studios' panel at
San Diego Comic-Con to confirm a spring 2021
release for Loki, hinting that the series
will answer fans' questions about where the
Avengers-era Loki went with the Tesseract
after disappearing during Endgame's time heist.
Of course, the character met a grim end at
the hands of Thanos in the brutal opening
sequence of Avengers: Infinity War, and his
death is expected to actually take this time.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, the series
will follow Loki as he, quote, "pops up throughout
human history as an unlikely influencer on
historical events," like a less-friendly,
time traveling Forrest Gump.
The project has scored a showrunner who should
know his way around this kind of material:
Michael Waldron, who has worked as a writer
on Adult Swim's Rick and Morty and will be
credited as creator and executive producer,
in addition to writing the pilot.
It's an inspired premise and a spot-on creative
choice, but let's face it: Disney+ had us
at "Tom Hiddleston will return as Loki."
"This universe is only one of an infinite
number.
Worlds without end."
2016's Doctor Strange gave us the MCU's first
look at the Multiverse, so it was only to
be expected that the sequel, which has been
in the works since before the first film even
released, should further explore the concept.
But this time around, it appears that traversing
multiple alternate realities will be central
to the plot, as evidenced by the flick's title,
revealed at San Diego Comic-Con 2019: Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness.
Returning director Scott Derrickson was previously
most at home in the horror genre, having helmed
such flicks as The Exorcism of Emily Rose
and Sinister.
For the further adventures of Stephen Strange,
Derrickson has promised that he'll deliver,
quote, "the first scary MCU film," on May
7, 2021, which sounds like an amazing prospect.
But wait, there's more: fans at SDCC were
also treated to the announcement that the
movie would co-star Elizabeth Olsen as Wanda
Maximoff/Scarlet Witch, along with her potent
and dangerous reality-warping powers.
It was also revealed that the film would tie
directly into the plot of the upcoming Disney+
series WandaVision, which will see Olsen reprise
the role along with Paul Bettany as a probably
less gray Vision.
We expected to see further team-ups along
the lines of the Thor/Hulk pairing in Thor:
Ragnarok for Phase 4, and we must say that
this one was quite unexpected, and inspired.
Among the more intriguing Disney+ limited
series is WandaVision, which will be run by
Captain Marvel writer Jac Schaeffer and will
feature the reunion of Scarlet Witch and Vision.
Of course, everyone's favorite robot boyfriend
was looking just a tad bit dead the last time
we saw him, during the climax of Avengers:
Infinity War, and he didn't return in the
"blip."
While it's not known exactly how the Avenging
android will make his return, there are a
few bread crumbs we can follow that give us
a clue.
Elizabeth Olsen has said that at least a portion
of the series takes place in the 1950s, which
doesn't make a great deal of sense unless
perhaps time travel is involved, or, perhaps,
alternate realities.
This seems a bit more likely, since we know
the events of Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness will tie into the events of the
series.
But It could be that Wanda will travel to
another world, one in which her lost love
is alive, but that, in doing so, somehow upsets
the balance of the Multiverse, leading a certain
good Doctor to intervene.
We won't know for sure until the series drops,
but it has been confirmed that the show will
take place after the events of Avengers: Endgame.
It won't be a terribly long wait to discover
how it will all shake out.
WandaVision is slated to debut on Disney+
sometime in the spring of 2021.
What If? is an alternate universe anthology
series which has run in various formats since
1977, exploring how events may have unfolded
if crucial moments in the mainstream Marvel
timeline had played out differently.
It allowed readers to consider scenarios both
intriguing (What if Spider-Man had joined
the Fantastic Four?) and unthinkable.
We're talking, "What if Doctor Strange were
a disciple of Dormammu?"
Well, what it did for the comics, the Disney+
animated series What If? intends to do for
the MCU.
Like its comics counterpart, What If? will
have an anthology format, with each episode
tackling one specific moment in the MCU timeline.
We know what you're thinking, what if Star-Lord
hadn't picked the exact wrong moment to cold-cock
Thanos?
We can already tell you: Infinity War would
have been a heck of a lot shorter and less
tragic.
We'll have to wait to see what weirdness this
animated outing will have in store for us.
We did get some definite hints about a few
possible scenarios during Marvel's 2019 Comic-Con
panel, which not only set a Summer 2021 date
for the show, but revealed an impressive line-up
of MCU talent set to lend their voices.
They will be joined by Jeffrey Wright in the
central role of Uatu the Watcher, likely a
Rod Serling-like host for the anthology's
multiverse-spanning speculations.
Rounding out the first batch of Disney+ limited
series will be Hawkeye, which will see Jeremy
Renner reprise his role as the Avenging archer.
The series' logo, which is heavily inspired
by the one used on the character's well-received
recent comics run from Matt Fraction and David
Aja, was dropped on the San Diego Comic-Con
crowd.
Along with the reveal came the confirmation
of a long-standing rumor: that the series
will see the debut of Kate Bishop, a young
protege who takes up the mantle of Hawkeye
in the comics.
The series is confirmed to take place after
the events of Avengers: Endgame, so it'll
likely see Clint Barton adjusting to a world
in which his beloved family has returned from
being dusted in the Decimation, and his trusted
ally Natasha Romanoff is no more, having sacrificed
herself to further the Avengers' mission in
Endgame.
While no plot details were announced, Renner
did share one little tidbit with the Comic-Con
crowd which suggests that Barton's mentorship
of Bishop will be key to the series' narrative.
He dished:
"I get to teach someone else how to be a superhero
without superpowers."
Fans have been clamoring for this storyline
to make its way to the screen for some time,
but they'll have to wait a bit longer to see
it come to fruition: Hawkeye is scheduled
to debut on Disney+ in the fall of 2021.
Given his fantastic character arc over his
last several appearances, culminating with
his decision to join the Guardians of the
Galaxy at the conclusion of Avengers: Endgame,
speculation had been running high for some
time that Thor would be the first Avenger
to land himself a fourth solo film.
It was confirmed in July 2019 that it was
happening, with Thor: Ragnarok's Taika Waititi
returning to direct, but at that month's San
Diego Comic-Con, further details were announced
that shocked those in attendance.
Specifically, the flick, now officially titled
Thor: Love and Thunder, releasing November
5, 2021, will see the return of Natalie Portman's
Jane Foster, who will follow in her character's
recent comic book footsteps by picking up
Mjolnir to become Thor herself.
Tessa Thompson will also return as Valkyrie,
and Kevin Feige has confirmed that this time
around, it will be made explicit that the
character is bisexual, a first for a major
character in an MCU film.
This, along with the flick's title, have led
some to speculate that the God of Thunder
just might find himself in the middle of a
complicated love triangle, one involving two
women who are just as powerful as he, and
who may prove to be slightly more interested
in each other than they are in him.
So far, so awesome, but we just have one question:
is this a brand new Mjolnir, or the same one
Captain America returned to 2013 in Avengers:
Endgame?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.